i know you guys can't share much but
what is the tea what can you tell us
give me the secrets it's all about
canada
the whole thing is about canada and
that's what it is and you're gonna love
it no it's not
it's a werewolf movie and it is you know
like the thing about monsters that i
love it's monsters are always struggling
with something you know they're they're
saddled with something that is that is
they can't control yeah and and it's
such a great way to think about things
in life i mean we all have these things
in our life that we're either ashamed of
or we're working on or we're trying to
be better at and i feel like
monster movies are an amazing way to
tell those stories and and and so we
tried to just go in as deep as we could
and tell a story about
people that care about something in
people that have this affliction that
still care about some but are still
working outward to be better and still
working out were to help each other and
and that's what we wanted to do that i
feel like the best monster movies
do that so that's the direction we went
oh well you got it okay and are you
going to be in moon knight
let's talk to moonlight about that
because uh yeah he's been you know
yeah there's no uh no immediate plans
for anything like that oh we got an
answer thank you